don't let the cute appearance of kenneth
bridges spirits deceive you combat in
this game is tougher than it looks
especially on its harder difficulties so
i'm here to give you a few general
strategies and tips as you progress
through the game to help you out and we
will be spoiler friendly if you enjoy
kena bridge of spirits subscribe to
gamespot to keep up with the latest in
gaming alright here we go
abuse your bow seriously once you get
the bow combat gets a little more
interesting its main use is to stun and
damage enemies by targeting their
courage weak points but keep in mind
that it's also good for farming bits of
courage over the fight as well every
little bit counts even if the damage is
minimal and yes there is a manual
slowdown ability that you can unlock
through your playthrough but also
shooting while jumping in the air
provides slow down as well without a
cooldown if you ever want to take a
couple second breather and survey the
surroundings on what to target next just
double jump and aim for a second to
strategize on what to do next
jumping is more powerful than you think
there are the standard defensive
abilities and can of bridge of spirits
pairing
shielding
and dodge rolling
but you'd be surprised on how many
attacks in the game can simply be jumped
over
this is actually the preferred method of
dodging attacks because you have the
ability to use the before mentioned
slowdown ability to counter attack while
dodging at the same time which none of
the other options have
here's a list of multiple useful things
you might not have known about in combat
shield sticks can be defeated with heavy
attacks but you can also defeat them by
shooting the small gap in its shield
the little explosive ticks can be
destroyed by simply pulsing them no need
to waste your arrows
small enemies can be disabled when a
bomb is thrown on them but also moths
are completely weighed down by an
attached bomb
and the best way to deal with multiple
pesky moths hands down is to bind
multi-shot an enemy then have the homing
shots do all the work for you and a
mage's magic bomb is parriable and can
be sent back towards them for good
damage
and talking about bombs your own bombs
while they won't damage you have the
ability to knock you off your feet which
can lead to an opening for an enemy
attack but if you learn the attack
sprint attack heavy you're able to
detonate the bomb and attack without
getting knocked back pretty nifty
parrying this is the biggest point of
contention parrying is all about knowing
what attack the enemy is going to do and
when the attack is going to hit you so
the biggest tip i can give is if you
don't know what the enemy is doing or is
going to do just don't try to parry it
this game has many attacks that are
delayed to purposely throw you off and
some that don't even look like attack
split can still damage you parrying in
this game has pretty strict timing and
failing to correctly parry will get you
killed quickly my suggestion is
obviously to learn the enemy patterns
first then bait them to do a specific
attack so you know when and where they
will strike that's the appropriate time
to parry take the wood knight for
example if you're at a distance 99 of
the time drawing your bow will cause
them to rush you down with the running
stab attack if you can bait them do that
and you know when it's coming parry away
or even purposely attack his defensive
stance shield to trigger his automatic
counter attack which you know is coming
so parry it right back
otherwise if you're going fresh into a
new boss fight with no understanding of
what their attack patterns are expecting
to parry no problem you might get one or
two off but you're probably going to die
and small side note if you're on ps5 or
pc set the game to performance mode or
60 frames per second parrying in 30
frames as with most action games is a
headache
pulse is useful as well not just
shielding while its main use is to
destroy corruption its other use is to
gather drops courage from a distance
without putting you in harm's way which
can be invaluable to top off that little
bit of extra courage you need to perform
your special rot attack
talking about courage like most games
this meter system can cap out which
means if you continue to attack while
you have full courage it's a complete
waste of hits you could be using to put
towards another meter of courage always
make sure you're being aggressive and
using courage as efficient as possible
but also maybe keep one held in the bank
in case of emergency if you need to heal
up
rot infused arrows and rod hammers look
pretty straightforward but have some
small quirks you might want to keep in
mind rod arrows are armor-piercing and
are definitely worth it when enemies are
lined up as they'll pierce through and
hit enemies that are standing together
more bang for your buck
rod hammers also do massive damage but
have two interesting traits they have
several invincibility frames during his
charge up which means you can't get hit
during the duration of this attack you
can use this to power through incoming
attacks also the rod hammer actually has
two parts the slam and the splash damage
doing this attack at close range right
at the tip of the staff will cause both
the slam and the splash damaged hit
doubling your damage
rod infused bombs are one of the most
useful techniques you'll get while
leveling up kenna but it slows down
enemies and incoming projectiles giving
you some breathing room to wail on your
opponent while it obviously uses one
courage bar when you use it its return
is higher than other techniques since
you have the ability to smack your
opponents around after they're stunned
so if you follow up quickly you can
usually gain back on average three
quarters of your current meter back they
just used up i'd say that's a pretty
good bargain deal to me
at last resort switch to story mode sure
if worse comes to worst your ego can
take a hit if you just want to enjoy the
game's story and progress further
there's nothing wrong with toning it
down for a fight that's just too
frustrating if anything you can tone it
down for just one battle you can't
handle then bring it back up after the
fight and for trophy hunters don't worry
about your first playthrough there's no
trophy tied to the difficulty settings
master spirit guide mode on the other
hand is another story you can't switch
difficulties on this mode so as the
saying goes suck it up buttercup you're
in for a tough ride now we'll go one
step further and leave you with an
advanced combat technique while it's not
particularly effective on smaller
enemies because jump attacks wiff
against them taller enemies and bosses
can be jump canceled against while it's
not overly powerful it does have the
ability to string together combinations
of attacks quickly to maximize your
damage done and courage gain during
counter-attacks
while you don't absolutely have to
remember everything here keeping at
least a couple of these in mind will
undoubtedly help you on your fights
through your journey with kenna and
remember we have more content as well
including the hardest difficulty
gameplay and a review of canada bridge
of spirits and for everything else
gaming keep it here on gamespot
oh
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
you